what makes for all of the things that
you've said I think a lot of people
would listen to everything you've said
say okay that all kind of makes sense
but actually Carl and probably Dave -
they're libertarians what makes you not
libertarian and more of a classical
liberal right okay now this this is um
oh god this is King it's a territory I
didn't think we were going to go into
last I'm not against the concept of
government now I understand that
libertarians are I think they're
therefore limited government small
government and on by that definition to
me that just sounds like common sense
why waste money on something that you
don't need if you don't need to have a
giant monolithic government entity why
do I have it you know why pay for it um
but I often find that libertarians tend
to go far too far with that for example
they you know they in America they seem
to be very much against social
healthcare and the welfare state and
they're they're a dumb room there are
definitive problems with the welfare
state and the rest of the world the
modern world is looking at you thinking
you don't have universal health care
everyone else does and we're getting
along okay I mean I hear your health
care is really good quality so there's
there's a but I I just I always I always
hear stories of people getting sick and
then going bankrupt from getting second
atomized the least humanitarian thing
ever um I was actually going to bring
this up a bit later on in actually but
since we're at it and let's most all
right now yeah so the I think the
difference comes from the fundamental
definition of freedom that I have and I
think that differs from the batarians
because libertarians they very focused
on government and I don't blame them
because the US government is a giant
almost out-of-control monster when it
when you look at like the things the US
government is doing around the world and
that's not even the worst it could be
doing it's actually surprisingly
restrained for such a giant beast but it
is doing terrible things and it has in
the past done terrible things and so I
can understand and especially this or
disconnect between the people and the
government these days and I mean that
was on
see part of the fun of watching Trump's
campaign was watching all of the powers
that be aligned behind Hillary Clinton
and then watching her lose that was I
mean she's been 1.4 billion on her
campaign you know with like you know all
of the you know Wall Street the the all
the banks almost all the politicians
almost all the press any other perfectly
academics anyone who thought they were
anyone we're all like well hey you've
all got to get behind Hillary she's
definitely the wind Trump has no chance
you know anyone who says anyone
otherwise is is insane and then Trump
wins and we see this just total
catastrophic collapse of their own
worldview I mean what can they say to
justify any of this well I mean we
didn't mean it what do you say right um
so um yeah so sorry I'm going off-topic
so basically my my issue is the
definition of freedom so I agree that's
being being wary of a giant government
power is definitely something that
anyone with any kind of like liberty
minded frame of mind should be concerned
obviously you know government is a dire
source of power but that's not the only
thing that can prevent a person from
being free and they lived here
libertarians seem to define freedom as
just freedom from government
interference whereas if you if you look
if you look at liberalism is in
historically I mean it wasn't
necessarily afraid of government it was
afraid of tyranny and there is there's
definitely forms of tyranny that come
from without the government I mean the
sjw's are the perfect example
they are social tyrants and they will I
mean it's really in it's really hardly
seen a number of professors as any it's
only about a handful it's only five or
six who have come out and in direct
opposition social justice like Jordan
pizzas and gout sad and a few others and
Christina Hoff Sommers who are who are
stridently anti social justice almost
universally on the fact that it's a
liberal and that sort of chilling effect
I think it has kept a lot of people
quiet but some and that that isn't
that's in itself a form of control it's
a form of oppression and it doesn't come
from the government and so
this is what I think libertarians need
to understand like for example poverty
is a man who has no house who has no
food who has no water he can't share he
can't wash he can't he can't dress
himself properly that's not a free man
even though the government isn't going
to be keeping him you know their thumb
honest he's not paying any tax he's not
a free man he can't do anything I mean
who's going to employ this person
where's he gonna sleep he's just that
this is not freedom this is just slavery
to poverty and so one of the things
about classical liberalism is it's not
necessarily against helping the poor I
mean I've got some I've got my copy of
the road serfdom here and I'm looking
forward to the libertarians explaining
to me page 124 125 which I happen to
have bookmark not splitted me for this
interview but just because I've had this
argument a few times where hey he
literally says well there's nothing
wrong with having a safety net there's
nothing wrong with social health care
these these things are not in violation
of any one's individual rights because
they protect everyone in the society so
yeah there's nothing wrong with that and
one of the things I think that people on
the Left have forgotten and and this is
why I think so many even think
right-wing when they think classical
liberal is they've they've listened to
libertarians who have said look we just
don't want any interference at all I say
okay well I appreciate that that's what
you want but it's not what you're going
to get because the second you get that
is the second you get a communist
revolution or something like that
because the people who need help
not in a good good for the parents being
in an upwardly mobile intelligent active
earning you know that they are all
really positive qualities gives you know
well not most but a lot of people in
society aren't like that and I think
there's Mark Carney the governor of the
Bank of England came out yesterday and
said look we've got to stop paying more
attention to what's happening to the
poorest in society because they're
getting restless their their lot is
getting too bad and he's right you know
it's about it's purely about
self-interest to be honest because if
you're not providing them with any
alternative means just saying well you
know screw yourselves what not our
problem
then there is nothing nothing at all
preventing some kind of populist from
coming along and saying hey I'll sort
your problems out just vote for me and I
think we've discovered in the past year
that they will do that on mass to the
point where everyone's like oh my god I
can't believe this
happening yeah and that's that's why I
don't like to say I told you so but this
is exactly what I've spent the last two
years talking about and you know when it
comes to immigration and Islam and a
whole bunch of other stuff and all this
trigger warning and safeSpace stuff and
people would say to me you know Dave
you're blowing this out of proportion
who cares if these college kids don't
want this or that or whatever and it's
like no actually there is something
happening to our society people are
afraid to say what they think and when
they're is afraid to say what they think
guess what it's very easy for a populist
or a demagogue or whatever else to come
in and give them some easy answers
you